now to an issue that every parent should
be paying attention to congress is
responding to calls for action to make
social media platforms safer for younger
viewers users the head of instagram went
to capitol hill yesterday where he
answered tough questions about the app's
potential harmful impact on teenagers
chris van cleeve is on capitol hill
chris good morning
good morning it was clear lawmakers
believe social media companies are not
doing enough to protect young people and
that new regulations are being drafted
we talked to one parent who said those
new rules can't come quickly enough she
blames social media for driving her
teenage daughter to the brink of suicide
i firmly believe that instagram and the
internet more broadly can be a positive
force in young people's lives adam
maseri the head of instagram faced a
grilling by lawmakers wednesday who say
the social media company is not doing
enough to protect young users instagram
sees a dollar sign when it sees kids
parents should see a stop sign
when it sees instagram you're the new
tobacco whether you like it or not our
kids aren't cash cows
missouri's testimony comes after
whistleblower francis haugen leaked
internal documents of instagram's parent
company formerly known as facebook she
claimed it showed the app could be
harmful when you saw your own study
finding a significant percentage of
girls
reported that
instagram caused them to think about
killing themselves
were you concerned by by that that
finding i'm concerned about anybody who
feels worse about themselves after using
the platform and certainly anyone any
one individual because we're talking
about people here not numbers
that has any suicidal thoughts ahead of
the hearing instagram announced it will
strengthen parental controls and launch
a take a break feature next year we've
just allowed our kids to
freely
go into these worlds sabina pollock says
social media apps drove her 14 year old
daughter to contemplate suicide what
they did to her was make her want to
kill herself it's changed how she views
herself how she will view herself it
changes how she views
life in general
pollock says her daughter is off social
media and recovering instagram paused
development of an app for 10 to 12 year
olds missouri is saying that was to give
the company more time to work with
parents and policymakers to create an
age-appropriate experience gail those
policy makers seemed pretty skeptical
conversation to be continued for sure
thank you chris